work on ewe's new wind farm rift gut
proceeded around the clock seven days a
week for a year
on sundays and holidays in wind and rain
for nothing as it turned out
the 30 wind turbines in the north sea
stand idle
and the workers are not happy
this
it's frustrating of course it's damaging
economically and it's a shame and
frustrating for the people who put
everything they had into this
and then nothing comes out of it
venezuela
rather than generating power the
turbines are consuming it
diesel generators have to be fired up
every day to activate the turbines and
keep them in working order
isn't it crazy to be running a wind farm
with diesel engines
yes
it looks that way at first glance but
the wind farm needs electricity to keep
from deteriorating it would be much
of undersea cable to operate
all but 13 kilometers have been laid by
the dutch electricity transmission
system operator tenet
but delays have been caused by bombs on
the seabed left over from world war ii
as tenet described it
the cable runs through an area where
there were unexpectedly large amounts of
munitions clearing them was an extremely
complicated task and was severely
hampered by poor visibility strong
currents and bad weather among other
things
the builders and operators of the wind
farm have little patience with such
explanations
ewe is accusing tenet of bad planning
we don't deny that there's ordinance
down there a lot of it and it's hard to
clear it away because it's underwater
and the divers can't see very well
everybody realizes that the problem is
we see it is that all this was already
known
we very clearly warned about it for the
first time in 2006
so they should have started on it
earlier it's a question of project
management
after all we got our wind farm done on
time
the delay is having repercussions in
emdin many suppliers and others were
depending on the wind farm
the wind turbine maker barred offshore
was counting on more orders but now
they'll be a long time coming
nazi vaca built the foundations for the
turbines but now the shipyard is defunct
investors were partly scared off by the
problems with the submarine cables
the emdan city council is also worried
about the community's future
of course we're disappointed here in
hamden because we've really been hoping
to be in a completely different
situation today where for instance
instead of 100 employees
bart offshore would have a thousand or
zeog
would be operating with five to seven
hundred employees
so lots of jobs were depending on this
in a relatively structurally weak region
east frisia had pinned a lot of hopes on
offshore development and so far
unfortunately nothing's come of them
the rifgot wind farm is now set to go
online in february of 2014.
at least that's the plan